bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france on imagine pascal rangée que vous
partagez la colère de vos confrères
évidemment on a un président qui nous
allons sonder un tas de guerre et
étatisme mars avril mai roubles 2 juin a
priori le 2 juin en partie le 18 juin
totalement on ne referme au mois deux 28
octobre jusqu'au 20 janvier a priori
nous on demande seulement mais vraiment
seulement 20% de notre chiffre
d'affaires
les périodes de fermeture pas le mois de
décembre ces panneaux l1 vous savez
aujourd'hui des habitants les gens ils
sont prêts à mourir à se suicider et
créer plutôt que d'un million de sauveur
on demande simplement 20% du chiffre
d'affaires
pas pour le mois de décembre pour le
mois de mars pour le mois d'avril pour
le mois de mai et voilà on comprend très
bien ce qui se passe mais on ne peut pas
nous abandonner comme ça en disant à la
télévision à présidente est allongé
sauce un ministre qui annonce une
deuxième chose et bercy enfin devons
qu'ils nous accordent que décembre sauf
pour les holdings souza been loving you
de détonner plusieurs établissements
vous avez strictement rien aujourd'hui
on ne fait pas l'aumône ont demandé de
faire survivre aux établissements pour
cette période de crise qui est
compréhensible mais on ne peut pas
mourir à cause d'une dinde indécision
d'état de terminaux à bisman s'il faut
que l'état soit responsable de ce qu'ils
font il faut qu'ils assument ce qu'ils
disent et on demande seulement tout le
monde demande sur le petit et moyen
laurent 20% de son chiffre d'affaires
des périodes de fermeture parce que vous
êtes aujourd'hui face à cette situation
dont vendant vos établissements comment
est-ce que vous gérez votre masse
salariale comment est ce que vous payez
votre vos factures au jour d'aujourd'hui
on a eu la chance que l'état nous avait
plaidé pge et dp je sais qu'après après
donc on n'est pas plus bête qu'un autre
un prêt c'est une terre qu'on doit
aujourd'hui on remercie l'état nous
avoir et c'était je remercie l'état
nous avons mis le chômage partiel à 80
4% pour les salariés s'étaient recul
quant au mois de mars abîmés ont été
fermés les salariés des tpe à 100 % des
salariés et des entreprises étaient bien
84% donc déjà il faut pas prendre les
salariés pour des idiots au jour
d'aujourd'hui les salariés pourquoi un
salarié dans des sociétés privées payées
à 84% et que les salariés l'état sont
payés
pour cent voilà un grand point
d'interrogation réunion des patrons
aujourd'hui c'est le pge qui nous ont
aidés à ne pas faire faillite
pour pouvoir assumer notait pour que ce
soit les marchandises ou des loyers des
murs etc
aujourd'hui si l'état nous débloque 20%
du chiffre d'affaires
on peut dire que nous sommes rang seront
pas cette étape de guerre comme dit le
président or maintenant on demande juste
et 20% et nous aurons la façon
d'attendre mais pourquoi attendre d'être
au pied du mur de d'avoir des gens qui
vont susciter des gens trop déposé bilan
et pourquoi on ne donne pas cet argent
entre guillemets facettes des aides qui
est d'une logique totale parce que c'est
un état qui nous ferme mise en avant par
le gouvernement
le protocole sanitaire dans les
établissements est ce qu'aujourd'hui il
est possible de le renforcer davantage
au jour d'aujourd'hui ça parce qu'ils
disent on avait mis tout en place que
soient les grands restaurateurs les
petits des moyens
aujourd'hui on avait bien compris il
fallait un espace on l'a fait
aujourd'hui on peut on va rien inventer
maintenant vous aviez des clients donné
dans dans les terrains sont comme aux
sports d'hiver sur les terrasses
il y avait ce rythme manque un danger
c'est des professeurs qui le dit donc
aujourd'hui ils se disent n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui tous les restaurants des
brasseries zèle effet il avait appliqué
les jets les masses les espaces entre
les tables et où donc aujourd'hui on
trouve à on va rien inventer
il faut juste il a su ce qu'ils disent
merci d'avoir pris le temps de réagir
sur notre antenne pascal ranger
propriétaires et dirigeants de plusieurs
brasseries à paris